une jeune fille de 9 ans témoin de
premier plan
l'exode de populations civiles fuyant
l'avancée de troupes étrangères gardera
toute sa vie même en temps de paix la
crainte de perdre les siens quand 25 ans
plus tard son pays sera de nouveau
envahi elle confectionnera pour ses
enfants de petits bracelets portant leur
nom et leur adresse dans l'éventualité
d'une séparation forcée
cette jeune femme s'appelait mathilde
était française et vivait à villemomble
à l'est de paris tout près d'ici
nous avons la mémoire courte nous aussi
nous avons connu l'exil l'histoire de
l'europe est empreinte du vécu et de
l'expérience de déplacements massifs de
populations civiles
fuyant la guerre mathilde était ma grand
mère près de cent ans plus tard
monzon jeune syrienne de 14 ans a trouvé
refuge dans le camp d'azrak en jordanie
non seulement aujourd'hui
monzon a pu poursuivre avec succès ses
études en jordanie mais est telle qu
elle est également une actrice engagée
de l'accès des réfugiés syriens à
l'éducation plus particulièrement celui
des filles
la délégation dont font preuve les
réfugiés syriens a mené une horde in une
à mener une existence la plus ordinaire
possible est remarquable en tant que
directeur adjoint du hr pour le
moyen-orient
j'ai eu le privilège de découvrir le
courage la résilience et la dignité dont
font preuve les réfugiés par rapport à
l'exil est également de découvrir
l'ensemble des aides qui leur sont
apportés si depuis 2015 plus de cinq
cent mille réfugiés syriens ont regagné
l'europe par la route des balkans la
majorité
vit toujours au moyen orient 4 8
millions de réfugiés syriens sont
enregistrées dans les principaux pays
hôte la turquie le liban la jordanie
l'irak et l'egypte aujourd'hui un
habitant sur quatre au liban est un
réfugié syrien ramené à l'échelle
européenne cela signifierait 125
millions de réfugiés syriens en europe
seuls 20% des réfugiés syriens réside
dans des camps la majorité résident au
sein de communautés locales composées de
préfabriqués organisé en damier zardari
en jordanie est le plus grand camp de
réfugiés syriens établis en moins d'un
an sa population de 80 mille résidents
est équivalente à celle d'une ville
comme la rochelle le quotidien de
tartarie a tous les attributs de la vie
d'une localité de cette taille questions
de logement avec l'attribution des
préfabriqués assistance aux plus démunis
question d'éducation de santé
implication des réfugiés dans la gestion
du camp la vie du camp est une véritable
ruche d'activité dès les premières
heures sa vie s'organise autour des
commerces situés sur l'artère principale
qui traverse le camp autour des écoles
des structures de santé et des
installations sanitaires dans un
contexte très différent les réfugiés
résidant au milieu des communautés
locales font aussi face à de multiples
défis pour la majeure partie ils font
ils subviennent à leurs besoins grâce à
leurs propres économies mais aussi aux
revenus très modestes des emplois
informels qu'ils sont réussis à trouver
notamment dans l'agriculture et la
construction
certains louent une ou deux pièces pour
cent ou deux cents dollars par
un garage établi remise que les
propriétaires ont décidé de louer
d'autres occupent des bâtiments publics
désaffectés ou ont établi des centres
communautaires le quotidien des réfugiés
syriens et précaires et chaque jour le
devient de plus en plus 70% des
populations réfugiées syrienne au liban
et 86% en jordanie vivre au-dessus
au-dessous du seuil de pauvreté
les dettes contractées par les réfugiés
pour subvenir à leurs besoins quotidiens
s'accroissent dramatiquement un nombre
de plus en plus important de réfugiés
potosi appels ont recours à des
stratégies de survie négative on retire
les enfants des écoles pour les faire
travailler mendicité mariage de plus en
plus précoces des filles et prostitution
nous devons les protéger dans les pays
limitrophes de la syrie
l'aide aux réfugiés est organisé à
plusieurs niveaux en première ligne les
communautés locales
le second niveau est constitué des
autorités nationales et municipales qui
ont fait preuve d'un courage et d'une
générosité exemplaire en accueillant 4 8
millions de réfugiés
le quotidien des réfugiés est précaire
et le devient de plus en plus les
réfugiés ont contracté de plus en plus
de dettes pour subvenir à leurs besoins
quotidiens
les pays de la région contribue un bien
public global c'est-à-dire une action
dans la responsabilité doit être
partagée
il est vital que cette responsabilité
soit partagé car elle est de l'intérêt
général
malheureusement la responsabilité
principale contrainte continue de
résider avec les pays hôtes qui on
continue haussier en supporter la
majorité des coûts facette importante
d'une répartition plus égale de cette
réponse de cette de l'aide
internationale en faveur de l'aide aux
réfugiés le hcr promet la réinstallation
d'un nombre croissant de réfugiés hors
de la région à travers différentes voies
légales la réinstallation classique visa
étudiant visa de travail et
réunification à familial comme l'a
souligné le haut commissaire aux
réfugiés les réfugiés mérite
investissements et actions au pluriel et
non indifférence et cruauté accueillir
et soutenir des réfugiés fuyant
bombardement violent et conditions de
survie de plus en plus précaire ce n'est
pas un acte de charité c'est une
obligation légale prescrites par le
droit international
c'est à vous de voir commun dans notre
humanité
il en est de l'intérêt général merci
[Applaudissements]